A vlog, this is a keynote,
my second keynote.
I gave two at ComplexCon and
this one had a lot of juice to it,
a lot of young entrepreneurship.
The framework of how I
see the game being played
right now and I hope you really enjoy it
and I'll talk to you soon.
(intense music)
(audience cheers and applauds)
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you, guys.
Appreciate you, how's everybody?
(crowd cheers)
Good,
so Ferg didn't make it this morning,
so we switched it to this afternoon.
Now Ferg's not making it again so,
he asked me to apologize on his behalf,
you know how rapper's do, so,
what I really wanna do,
the mic is set up here.
I'm gonna rant a little bit
but for a lot of you, I
know that a lot of you
know my two cents, my
spiel, I know a bunch
of you came through the booth,
so I wanna thank you so much for that.
I appreciate you supporting K-Swiss and I
but the mic's there, I highly recommend,
I'm probably gonna go into
it like 10 or 15 minutes,
so if you've got questions,
this is kind of the opportunity,
so feel free to start
lining up over there.
My man, that's not wasting time.
So cool, let me set up a
little bit of a framework
before we get into the Q and A,
talk about a little bit
what I wanna talk about.
First of all, it's super
amazing to be here because
just the vibe of this event
is a lot of fun for me
because, as some of you know,
I grew up a baseball card kid and
as soon as I walked
down to the convention,
I was like, oh shit, I know this flavor.
This was baseball cards, 1989, like,
the level of entrepreneurship
that I saw downstairs,
people literally wanting to
fight over their position
in line because they knew
they had to get a better one
to flip their shit, I respect that shit.
I know people are
frowning on the fighting,
I recommend it.
(audience laughs)
People are trying to eat, you know, so,
that was amazing and
just the level of culture
and more importantly,
I'm old, so I grew up
where everybody was kind
of divided when it came
to hip-hop and culture and everybody kind
of stayed in their own lanes,
just watching this generation
bleed into each other,
white, brown, yellow, black, green,
it's just fucking incredible and honestly,
people shit on millennials all the time.
I think some of you know
I'm like the reverse,
I think the fucking
millennials are the best.
I know nothing but lazy
people that are older,
so, maybe a little
entitlement just 'cause things
have been good so you
don't know the difference.
How many people under 30, raise your hand.
Right so, for all of you,
the big thing that you
need to keep in mind
is you haven't been punched
in the fucking mouth yet,
2008, 2001, 2000, 9/11,
the stock market crash,
the Bear Stearn shit, the
biggest thing that you
don't know yet is when
the whole economy crashes,
you go from being an
entrepreneur of a t-shirt company
to working at Bank of
America because the money
gets sucked out of the system so,
I'm not trying to frown on anything,
I'm trying to put everybody
in the right perspective.
Everybody under 30 here
understands it better,
the places that people pay attention to,
which is the only thing
I give a fuck about,
the way you guys
collaborate with each other
and have love for each other,
way better than ever before,
the only vulnerability
that this room has is
lack of blood pouring out of their mouth
and I mean that, 'cause
there's so much money
in the system, like it
feels normal to sell
shit through Instagram
until 20% more people
don't have money to spend
on stuff and then the
shit gets tight and so,
I highly recommend, where
I'm going with that,
is not like (groans), where
I'm going with that is
get practical.
A lot of people are just not practical.
A lot of people take in money,
instead of investing it
back into their business,
buying dumb shit.
There was a whole lot of dumb
shit buying downstairs today.
(audience laughs)
There was.
There was a bunch of
people that bought shit
to make money, that's good buying shit.
There's a lot of people
buying shit downstairs today
to close the gap on
insecurities that they have.
(audience cheers)
A lot of people bought
shit because they think
the logo on their hoodie or on their kicks
is gonna make them feel
better, but it's not
and it's gonna speed up
the process of you losing,
not the other way around so,
we need more practicality in
this space, that's for sure
but if you came to this
and clearly you did,
'cause we're here,
but I'm talking to the people watching,
if you came to this,
you're fucking so much more
ahead of people.
I was trying to tell people downstairs,
for a lot of you, you've
been fucking with this
kind of game, whether
it's hip-hop or sneakers
or street or urban, you've
been fucking with it,
probably maybe even your whole life, right
or maybe for a little while.
The number one thing and I'm gonna say it,
as an outsider, even though I fuck with it
and it fucks with me,
the number one thing that
you guys need to understand
is this shit hasn't even started yet.
Everything that's happening here is what
it's gonna be,
you think that's what it is right now
'cause that's your reality
because you haven't lived
in enough places, tasted
enough shit and been
in enough rooms.
For example, Nike's a big shot downstairs
but why do they spend 90%
of their advertising money
on dumb shit that you
don't pay attention to?
Why did Under Armour go
from being in the game
to being completely out of the game,
nobody gives a fuck
about Under Armour here.
How did that happen in 36 months?
'Cause they acted like Nike.
So, be real smart about what's going on.
Be real smart about what's going on,
I heard somebody say Durant,
fucking Under Armour was
sitting on Steph Curry
at the fucking apex, right,
Jordan Spieth at the apex,
they got Tom fucking piece
of shit Brady, right?
- [Audience Member] Take it easy.
I get it.
(audience laughs)
My man, this is me taking it easy, my man.
And so, and so they have
all that and you know
what they couldn't do?
The thing that comes natural
to everybody in this room.
They couldn't trade culture.
They put out piece of shit sneaker after
piece of shit sneaker,
they took for granted
where your attention was
and they thought if they're
gonna drop the Steph Curry's,
they're gonna do that as
a three minute commercial
during the NBS finals
and you guys were all off
watching the finals,
it went to commercial,
you took out your phone
and you're looking at
highlights at @dunk on Instagram,
not the fucking commercial.
People don't get it.
You get it.
Here's what you don't get.
You fucking lack patience.
All of you that just
came through my booth,
all your fucking questions,
they all came down
to the same shit.
Too many of you talk about being it,
but you're not living it.
You wanna be about patience and hustle,
it's fun to say to me, it's fun to tweet
that you're a fucking entrepreneur.
It's a lot harder to bleed
15 hours a day, everyday,
for 15 years.
One of my best friends in
the world, Dustin Sing,
fourth row back, that
man and I drove back from
Mount Ida College the day we left college.
We drove back, yapped it up, reminisced,
this was it, it was over,
reminisced, got to the parking
lot around 3:00 that day,
we hugged it out, he went on his way,
took a train, I walked
into the liquor store
as a 22 year old and I talked to that man
five to 15 times for the
next eight years, true?
It fucking worked, it was patient,
fucking bled, grinded, for real,
not, now it's made up my
narrative as an entrepreneur
and it's cool, I lived it.
There's not a lot of people that know it
but he does, he knows the truth.
He knows in college I went
fucking home every weekend
on the Amtrak, not Acela,
I wasn't fancy back then
and fucking went and
worked and I'd come back.
I left for the weekends.
He also knows I didn't go to class, ever.
He was also phenomenal at video games.
He should be an E-Sports star,
but that's another story for another day.
Nonetheless, the bottom line is,
when people ask me
questions or when I talk
or things of that nature,
the difference is, I lived it.
I don't just talk about it and
I get why you don't wanna do it
and it comes from insecurity.
You're worried.
You know why you guys aren't patient?
'Cause you wanna win
already to fucking stick it
to your fucking parents, right?
The reason you're
impatient is less about you
wanting to buy certain shit,
though a lot of you are fucked
up on that bullshit game,
it's more because people
are telling you you can't,
you decide to do your
own thing and now you're
on the clock and everybody's
watching and your
grandma's telling you you
should have stayed in school
but you've gotta understand,
it doesn't matter if you
win in the first half,
it doesn't matter if you're up 17
going into the 4th quarter,
you've gotta win the actual game.
You need to be shit on
in your 20s and 30s,
so then you can fucking
clown on people in your 40s
and I tell them I fucking told you.
You understand?
(audience applauds)
And the best part is you
gotta love the fucking losses.
Do you know how happy I am right now
that they put a c before
the k in my last name
and misspelled it?
(audience laughs)
I'm being dead serious.
This is going great, I
love your admiration,
the number one thing I'm excited about
right this fucking second onstage,
is they misspelled my fucking name.
(audience laughs)
'Cause I look at that and I'm like yes,
'cause I love losing.
You know why I gave up on
the Rangers and the Yankees?
'Cause they won championships.
You know why I fuck with
the Jets and the Knicks?
'Cause they suck
and that is the fundamental difference
and I promise you, my friends,
it's binary.
This whole thing, your
fucking life if binary.
It's a one or a zero, it
is black or is it white,
you are either gaining
or you're declining.
There is no in between,
you're not kind of passive
right now, you're not
kind of in the middle,
you're either winning
or you're losing, right,
and you've gotta understand
that all the things
that you want, of course
they should be hard.
Do you understand the
audacity, do you understand
that if you make $400,000 a year,
that means you've entered
the top 1% earners in this country?
People talking about millions as like,
I gotta make a million as an entry point
and they don't even
understand that 99% of people
in America don't make $400,000 a year.
We've got the whole game mis-framed.
Everybody confused.
Let me tell you what you should focus on.
A, you need to do some shit you like,
'cause if you don't,
you will be outworked by
somebody who loves that thing
and they will beat you.
Uh-huh, that's the problem.
If you don't love it,
somebody will beat you
because they love it
and that means they'll work 18 hours a day
'cause you fucking love it
and you're working 11
'cause you like the money
that comes along with it
or eight or supposedly
you're working 10 but it's really four
and you're bullshitting and
watching YouTube for six
and so, I am confused by
people's inability to be humble,
especially this audience
and I'm stereotyping
but let me tell you something
that's pissing me off
that is the great advantage
of the collective culture downstairs.
I think the reason I'm patient and I think
all the strengths I have
about all the things
I'm preaching right now is
'cause when you don't come
from much, you already know.
You already know that you can be happy if
you have a good household.
You already know that you don't
need a whole lot of stuff.
You already know one nice
pair of kicks is enough
if you can't afford another.
You already know.
In life, you have two situations, binary
and they're both winning formulas
or they're losing formulas
and they start the same way.
You were born
and you were either born with too much
'cause your parents are
rich and they got shit,
like my kids,
or your born with too little,
the way I was born in a
fucking piece of shit house
in Belarus in Russia, right?
That's it.
You're either born with
too much or too little
and boths are strengths and weaknesses.
You're fucking mindset decides it.
I sit in rooms everyday
and you guys know I love
to sit with kids and jam and do shit,
almost everyday I have a
situation, every month,
I will meet at least one
person that's gonna cry to me
that they don't have
anything and it's hard
and they didn't get lucky
and they got nothing
and it's hard and then I
will equally have dinner
with somebody else who
will tell me that it's hard
and difficult, happened today downstairs
because they had too much.
They're not hungry 'cause their parents
did everything for them.
Their mom and dad fucked them up because
they gave them too much,
which the people that have nothing,
a bunch of you just sat,
I have people who have 50
million dollar trust funds
cry to me at dinner that their life sucks
because they've never fought for anything.
They never did anything and
they don't have any purpose
and they're lost and they're suicidal,
which, the people in here
that were born with nothing
are like, fuck you.
(audience laughs)
Right?
A bunch of you are like, fuck that, right?
It's 'cause you don't
know the alternative.
Everybody's pointing at everybody else
without understanding.
Nobody's deploying empathy.
Everybody's worried
about what's their issue,
without realizing everybody's
got fucking issues.
My friends, let just get to the punchline.
Nobody gives a fuck about your problems.
Nobody gives a fuck about
your problems because either,
it's true,
either, either, they've got
their own fucking problems,
or they're just focused on some other shit
but they can't empathize with
you and more importantly,
if you think that somebody
owes you something
'cause you started at a disadvantage,
you're a fucking loser.
You have to understand,
that's your advantage.
Who do you think fucking rises and wins?
Have you guys paid attention to what's
actually happening on Earth?
Have you guys paid attention
to who actually wins?
It's fuckers that had nothing,
that had motivation to get something.
We don't fucking know
stories about he had this
and then all of a sudden he made it big,
nobody gives a fuck about that story.
There's no glory in that
story and guess what?
That story doesn't exist a whole lot.
You've got a lot of second
generation people doing stuff,
but by the third generation, everybody got
so fucking soft, they're
even doing non-profits
all the time or they wasted all the money.
(audience laughs)
I just ask you, would you much rather
do you know I used to cry
in college 'cause my dad
had a liquor store and I was like,
nobody's ever gonna give
me credit because they're
gonna always think I got like,
I was upset that there
was a little something
and he was around, he knows,
it's not what everybody
wants it to be when
they're fucking coming
up with excuses why I won
and they didn't, I won 'cause
I fucking outworked you.
I won because I had enough
self-awareness to understand
what I was good at.
There's a lot of shit I wish I was,
I just figured out what
I was and what I liked
and then I just fucking outworked you
and I will always outwork
out because I love the game
more than the stuff.
You just have to understand that.
When you fucking love it,
you can't beat me because
I wanna do it every second
that I'm breathing and so I need people
to get to that place.
The reason I'm doing
everything I'm doing right now
that you're paying
attention to is 'cause I'm
trying to become your excuse, your shield,
your thing that you can point to
because if you trip and fall,
you guys are worried about failing
and I'm trying to get you to point at me
and blame me that it didn't
work versus blaming yourself
so that it gives you
the courage to actually
start doing shit.
The only way you're gonna
get the thing that's
been running through your mind,
the only way you're
gonna get on that plane
that you think you wanna be on
when you were sitting
downstairs eating french fries
with your homie and
chopping it up and saying
what we're gonna be in seven years,
is if you fucking outwork everybody,
figure out what you're good at,
bring value to the people
you're trying to sell
and just rinse and repeat
forever till the end
and so everybody looks at
the people that made it.
(audience member sneezes)
Bless you, everybody looks
at the people that made it
and none of you looked
at how they got there,
simple as that.
Everybody in this room, I promise you,
my superpower is empathy.
I never make--
- [Audience Member] It's true.
It's true.
(muffled speaking by audience member)
It's because, my man, I
don't think my employees
should work as hard as I do and a bunch of
dumb fucking business people do.
If my employees should
work as hard as I do,
they should have as much equity as I do.
How the fuck do you want somebody to work
for as much as you do when it's yours,
you fucking audacious piece of shit?
I have empathy, I don't
know what's going on.
If you're not performing, it
might not be work-related,
your grandma might be sick,
I'm empathetic, that's
why I'm a great salesman.
You know why I can sell you anything?
'Cause I think about you first.
I'm not worried about what's in it for me,
I'm trying to figure
out what's in it for you
and then give you more
than you even expected,
I'm trying to guilt you
fuckers into my shit.
(audience laughs)
And that's it and that's
why I fucking put scrutiny
on everybody who's trying
to do courses and prerolls,
trying to get you to pay 4,000 for this
and 10,000 for that and all this.
This shit is simple.
All the information is
free, you don't need any
of that other shit.
It's fucking free.
People are paying for shit
to make them feel better
about not doing shit.
Let me say it again.
Watch this, how many of you,
when you first came across me,
don't lie, lying is the devil,
how many of you, when
you first came across me,
said fuck this guy, I hate
this guy, raise your hands.
Raise 'em high.
You know why?
I was suffocating you.
I was suffocating your fucking excuses.
There's a lot of people who's
much rather, much rather,
pay somebody to make
them feel good about why
they're not doing 'cause
there's some so fucking secret
process that's gonna get you on.
Let me give you the secret,
once and for all, right here.
Work, a lot, based on
what your mouth is saying.
You wanna be a millionaire?
You need to become a workaholic.
Right?
You wanna have a good work/life
balance and great family
and be on the softball
team and raise your kids
and make 100 thousand, let
me just say it real quick,
that's a ridiculous life,
making a 100 thousand,
and like 47 thousand, and see your kids,
and do you thing and
be happy, that's great
but don't talk shit, talk your reality.
Talk your truth, create a framework
that you can fucking follow
because the only people
listening to your excuses
or your bullshit are your
loser fucking friends
and you've got to, it's true, man,
people sit in little
circles with four people,
everybody gassing each
other up to not do shit.
(audience laughs)
It's true, I'm watching,
I'm watching all of you,
I was downstairs taking
selfies, signing shoes
and watching and listening.
I listen real fucking careful,
I watch you real quick,
nobody, nobody is putting
on marathon sneakers,
everybody wants to be sprinter.
Everybody wants it tomorrow
and I get it.
It seems like it's real
delicious over there
but let me tell you what
happens when you start
getting higher and higher
and Diddy said it right,
more money, more problems is real.
You wanna have a million dollar business
that you're the CEO and
the entrepreneur of?
Let me tell you what happens.
You're eating shit for a living.
You're a firefighter.
I'm about to get off this stage right now
and there's seven things I
gotta fix, problems, issues,
so, grass is fucking
greener until you live it
and so, if you leave with anything,
let's break down the core
things and then we'll
get into Q and A.
Number one, first and foremost,
we need to put empathy on a pedestal.
It is the fucking trait.
You know what's fun for me?
I'm all alpha and
competitive and dude it out,
the shit I believe in is
the most emotional, crying,
real things, girly, as
people try to tell me,
it's not girly, it's strength.
Do you know what happens
when you expect nothing
from nobody?
Do you know what it
feels like to live a life
when you just give, give,
give and you never ask
for anything in return?
Do you know what it feels
like to, in every situation,
think about how the
other person's feelings,
even if they're fucking you up?
Right, what was it, Bronx
Tale where the guy was like,
is that the movie where he's like,
you're better off, it
only costs you 20 bucks?
I believe in that shit.
That fucking scene was
legit, that's right.
You know how people
sitting here still dwelling
about some dumb shit
that happened in 2011?
(audience laughs)
Like, it's a fact, man.
People send me emails, like,
my mom stole $50 from me
in 2013, I'm like,
cool, I'll send you $50,
shut the fuck up.
(audience laughs)
These are the DM's I'm getting.
My best friend's not
working as hard as me,
cool, split up and let's see who wins.
Everybody knows the answers,
people just don't wanna do shit.
Even as I'm standing here, I'm like, fuck,
why am I talking about anything else,
people don't wanna do it.
People are gonna come up with
a million different reasons
why they can't and that's
why the next pillar
matters to me the most.
You know why I have so much energy?
You know I've been going
the whole time here?
I'm grateful, gratitude
and I've been grateful
from the get, not 'cause I got stuff now,
I was grateful when I was
building my dad's liquor store
for him, making $31,000 a
year, having no social life.
I was grateful because I
was conditioned and was in
a place that I was paying
back my parents for
putting me on, right?
I'm grateful everyday when
I wake up and people I
care about aren't stick.
I just don't get it.
Why do people start caring
about the shit that matters
when they get scared?
Everybody's living life, you
know like when you're driving
and the cop lights go on and
then your fucking heart goes
but then when the cop drives by,
you're like (sighs), you feel real good
and then you start driving with two hands
and the speed limit for about four minutes
and then you go back to
being like ridiculous?
That's how people are living their lives.
Like Grandma gets sick
or Mom has a cancer scare
or they get sick or
something and then they
start caring about real shit.
Nobody's giving a fuck
about a Supreme backpack
when your health isn't going anywhere
and so I just don't understand why people
are living their lives like that
and so, fucking gratitude.
Whatever you got, listen,
if you could afford $90
or $60 or whatever the fuck
you paid for this conference,
you are so much further
along than the majority
of the Earth, you just haven't
put the right perspective
in place.
You have not put the right
perspective in place.
People complaining downstairs
wearing $213 shoes.
Shut the fuck up.
Get perspective.
What the fuck do you think
is going on in the world?
Get out of your fucking bubble.
People talking about being in
the 'hood and they're like,
then I start poking and they're like,
in lower middle class, right, in America,
with the fucking internet,
do you guys understand
that you have a fucking
thing on you that is more
powerful than fucking
every media company had
fucking 25, 30 years ago,
in your fucking pocket?
We could just laugh about,
listen, I could go on forever.
People are lacking gratitude,
people are lacking empathy,
you know why people like me?
'Cause I like them first.
That's it and so everybody's
watching what I'm doing
and this and that,
and then I'm saying things and
you guys are really helping,
you guys are like my Puff Daddy,
the hmms are coming in.
(audience laughs)
You're feeding me, keep
doing it, I love it,
I'm like, I was about to
sit down but those hmms
are like, oh shit, I
better say something else
fucking fresh.
I need a couple more hmms
before I sit the fuck down.
I'm gonna come up with
a little more fresh.
(audience applauds)
And everybody hears this and listen,
some of you have been consuming
this for a year or two,
you watched those videos
on Instagram or YouTube,
you've watched my vlog or this and that,
you listen to podcasts, you get hyped,
you get hyped and you're like right
and then you stop
listening and you walk out
into your real life and
you go back to dumb shit.
Here's why.
A lot of that stuff happened early.
Where you grew up, how you were raised,
biggest problem is,
if you have parents that are pessimistic,
misery loves company,
it's hard to break that.
It's hard to face the fact that your mom
wants you to actually lose.
She doesn't realize it,
you know that, right?
Your mom doesn't want you to lose,
it's her framework.
I watched my grandma, it's true,
I watched my grandma parent my dad,
well, I didn't watch her parent my dad
but I watched a lot of shit.
I watch what my mom did with me,
I watch other people like
your mom fucked you up.
Your dad fucked you up.
That's real but you've got to understand,
instead of sitting here and
dwelling and blaming them,
you're in control of your own shit.
You got one fucking at bat,
do something with it and now, honestly,
now that you have this, guys,
do you understand why Harvey
Weinstein and Kevin Spacey
are getting called out?
It's because the internet
is now the middleman,
not five to 10 media companies
run by 10 old white guys.
You can tell me anything
you want about Trump this
or this, that or the other thing,
you're missing the point.
You're missing the point.
You know why Champion
can come back real quick?
'Cause they did the
right shit for 24 months.
You know why everybody
wears fucking Stan Smith's?
'Cause they put them on
cute girls on Instagram
three years ago.
You know why people drink
LaCroix fucking sparking water?
'Cause they spent their
money on Instagram.
You know why Under Armour isn't winning?
'Cause they didn't.
I'm not mad at Under
Armour, I'm just using it
'cause you just lived the last five years
and watched which brands
won and which ones didn't
and so like, it's funny
to me just watching it,
you get it, you got the part that matters,
you get it.
What, you think Under Armour
and Nike wanted Adidas
and Supreme and all
these things to happen?
They didn't.
They just did the wrong shit.
You know why?
They took their spot for granted.
They just took it for granted
and that made the vulnerability
and now, it's over.
Just so everybody knows,
just like the internet,
this whole culture, fashion, street,
all that, it's over.
My K-Swiss deal with Barney
and Patrick and those guys,
that's the preview, not the anomaly.
Every brand's about to do
collaborations with things
that matter, forever and ever and that's
where the equity is.
Yeah, there might be a
Jordan and a couple things
in sports but in life,
there's unlimited
opportunities and everybody's
starting to kind of figure it out and so,
huge opportunity in this space,
huge opportunity in everything,
the problem is, do you have
the next pillar, number three,
which is, do you have humility?
Do you have humility?
Andy K, you here?
Yo, check your DM because
I just engaged with
two influencers on our
sneaker thing while I was
in the backroom one second
before I came out here.
Thank you.
Because I'm still back
there with the humility
of thinking somebody
who's got 47,000 followers
on Instagram, that it might do something
for my K-Swiss joint, that
I'm willing to personally
write it and be like, hey,
you wanna do something
and people here that got
nothing, aren't even started,
aren't willing to DM
a hundred people a day
'cause you're fucking fancy
and you think you're somebody
and guess what, you haven't even started,
no one even knows who the fuck you are.
I'm confused as fuck by that.
Do you have humility?
Do you have the humility to put
in the fucking work, period.
Everybody's trying to graduate
into some place, my
friends, the bigger you get,
the more you have to work for them.
I have 800 bosses, not 800 employees.
I work for everybody at VaynorMedia,
not the other way around.
You've got it twisted.
This world that you think exists doesn't,
for the people really out there doing it,
not playing it on YouTube,
you've got to figure out
what's really happening.
You need to wake up and you need to put in
the fucking empathy for
your audience because
you'll never make a good product,
never sell shit unless
you actually worry about
them being happy with it.
You need to put in real
gratitude that you're even
lucky enough, do you
understand your grandparents,
think about your fucking grandparents,
they didn't have no internet.
They had to work the job and go to sleep.
The fact that you can
work your nine to five
to pay off your debt or
pay your rent or take
care of what you can
have to and then you can
take out your phone and fucking work from
7PM to two in the morning,
that's a fucking blessing.
That's a fucking opportunity
and nobody can stop you
and nobody decides but
us, it's fucking crazy.
So you better start really
fucking deploying gratitude
and everybody, change your
fucking mindset today.
Make this the fucking talk
that changes your mindset.
Stop fucking bitching, nobody's listening,
nobody gives a fuck, stop expecting shit
and go fucking take yours
by doing the last part,
which is having number
three, the fucking humility
to put in the fucking
work because if you don't,
somebody with real fucking
chops is going to deploy it
and take yours, understood?
(audience murmurs yes)
Cool.
(audience applauds)
Now, now that you've got your mind right,
it's about one thing,
understand where the attention
is and make shit for it.
Everything I've been kind
of nuanced over there
about the Under Armour
and Champion thing is
if you would have told
anybody in business 24 months ago that at
ComplexCon, where thousands
of kids that are cool
are hanging out, that more
of them would be wearing
Champion product than Under Armour,
you would have been laughed
out the fucking room.
That took two minutes.
That's why attention is so important.
Attention's so important
because if you're not smart
about it, you will lose.
When MTV came out, they went
to the biggest rock bands
in the world and they
asked them to make videos
and most of them said no
because they weren't willing
to give away free music and
they were playing stadiums
and getting paid and 36 months later,
nobody gave a fuck about
them and they gave a fuck
about Madonna and Michael
Jackson and Rod Stewart
and Duran Duran and
whoever made shit for it.
Our MTV sits in this place,
our MTV comes across in
four or five platforms,
Instagram and Snapchat, right?
Instagram and Snapchat are
MTV and BET, you understand,
except it's not 1992 anymore
and so what you are trying to do everyday
is become the TRL, right,
you're trying to become the
show and every one of you
can do it and it doesn't
cost you any money.
The problem is, most of
you are losing because
you're fronting on your content because
you're not willing to be
authentic 'cause you think
you gotta play a part
and the ironic thing is,
all the magic is in the shit
that is corny, it just is,
because you all look the same.
If you're all playing
up to the same standards
of what's cool and what's
good and what's good content,
you end up all looking the same.
(audience member mumbles)
100% my man, I mean, I now
have declared every single
human on Earth ridiculously hot because
everybody's figured
out angles and lighting
and filters and I go on
fucking Instagram, I'm like,
fuck, everyone's hot.
(audience laughs)
How are you a point of
differentiation if you know
how to kick up your heel
and kick your ass out
and that's all you see for 74
people in a row in your feed?
I don't know your fucking name
and every dude's doing the same dumb shit,
like taking off their, it's the same shit,
whatever it is, whatever
it is all the shit
that got me to where I was
was I never gave a fuck
about you, I was never
going to pander to what
you decided at that moment was cool.
I was gonna live my life
and then I got lucky
and it stumbled into entrepreneurship
getting a little cooler.
Everything that's gonna make your shit pop
is in the stuff that your
parents and your sister
knows about you but not
even your best friend.
The corny shit in your
stomach is the magic,
you just need to share it with the world.
Please think about that
because everything else becomes noise
but your real personality, your nuance,
that's the only currency
you can trade on 'cause
that's the only thing not replicable.
Got it?
Like the video I posted
just now, right now,
that's doing super well about like,
fuck up on purpose, you guys see this?
In it, my voice got so high,
you saw that?
How many of you saw that?
Everybody in the comments like,
yo, fuck this Mickey Mouse pussy shit.
(audience laughs)
And I read it and I
click on it and the guy's
living at home with 106
followers and I reply
to him like, that Mickey
Mouse shit is why this won.
The nuance, be you, be
fucking you 'cause it's
the only shot you got
at beating somebody else
and I'm very proud of this space,
this space, culture, street, hip hop,
was a space when I was a kid,
that rappers made of their origin story
because if they grew up
in a middle class family,
the market wouldn't accept them.
People made up their shit,
they once visited their uncle in Compton
and like, yo, I'm from Compton.
I'm so proud of this
space that now we accept
regardless of the angle, skin tone,
it's incredible what you
guys have done with it,
so you can't be scared
of anything, just be you.
It's all you got.
Thank you.
(audience applauds)
Let's do it.
- [Audience Member] What's up, Gary.
I just want to say thank you.
Yo, for the two guys leaving,
this is the best fucking part.
The Q and A's where the fire is.
This is gonna be the best question too.
I know you were in Oslo
just a few days ago
and now you're here,
I know my parents never
had this communication,
so I just want to say
thank you for giving back,
when we didn't, like my
parents never had this
and we have this now, it's awesome.
So, my question's kind of
left side, I don't know but,
I don't really get to have this,
so entrepreneurs that are making it,
that have a lot of success,
let's say you become a multimillionaire,
so I'm gonna use you for an example,
it's like a marriage question but
how do you, not balance but,
if you make it, how effed
up is your family life,
like bouncing it with your wife?
It just depends on who
you're fucking with, right?
Like it depends on who your partners are.
You got to over-communicate.
Everybody wants different shit.
Like, it could be really fucked up.
Or your kids are like, hey dad,
why aren't you ever
home, I know you're out
spending time with--
My dad was never home.
I didn't see him until I was 15
and dragged into his
liquor store and we had
the best relationship ever and I love him
with all my heart.
Like, guys, the current state
of political correctness
and how you should parent,
how you should live,
what age you should get married at,
that's all bullshit.
There's only one story, yours.
You need to communicate
with the people you give
a shit about in your inner
circle and the next circle,
there's people that are
home nine to five everyday
that are fucked up.
There's people that spend
everyday with their spouse,
everyday, they both
work in the home office,
and they're gonna get
divorced in nine minutes
'cause it's fucked up.
There's no right size fits all.
Let me tell you how you
really solve what you're
trying to say.
You guys wanna be selfless
and be good and give back?
Be selfish first and get
your shit to the place
where you need to be.
So when you were like in the
process of getting married,
were you like, hey dude, I'm gonna be.
Yes, I looked at her and said hey dude.
(audience laughs)
No but like, real quick.
I'm just using your, I was
like, I'm gonna buy the Jets
and you think I'm gonna slow
down and I'm gonna gear up.
I'm working harder now than ever.
This is the hardest I've ever
worked in my life, right now.
I went to Oslo and then Copenhagen,
connected to Moscow, got here,
leave for Australia, tomorrow
night I'm in Australia,
fucking, Tyler,
Tyler fucked me the fuck,
not you Baben, Tyler Schmidt,
Schmidt really fucked me up.
I'm in fucking Australia
for 30 hours, four keynotes,
he gave me two hours of sleep.
- [Audience Member] Wow, thanks Tyler.
You know and so like,
this is like the hardest I've ever worked
and it is what it is, right?
You just do the best you can, bro.
That's it, you just do
the best you fucking can
because the truth is
when you get to that
place in your own head
and you're living in your own head,
you don't care what other people think.
I don't care what my parents think.
I don't care what my spouse thinks.
I don't care what my kids think, I don't.
I want it to be awesome
but I got to start with me.
So do we come in to a
relationship thinking.
Over-communicate.
Be like, hey dude, I wanna be big.
(audience laughs)
- [Audience Member] For sure, thank you.
(audience applauds)
Check, check, oh, they fucked
up, they gave me the mic.
First off, give a shout out
to whoever put this complex
'cause this is an amazing event.
I came from the real estate wealth expo
and I saw GaryVee coming and it was like
Brendon Burchard or
GaryVee and I was like,
oh, fuck Brendon Burchard, I
wanna see GaryVee, you know?
So, but attitude, gratitude,
I just want to thank you
for spitting real shit.
That's it, the thing's
you're saying is so right,
what really matters is all
fun and happy and everything
but what really matters is
tomorrow, Monday morning,
what are you doing by yourself
with the rah, rah, rah,
all that stuff, so I just
wanna say, I appreciate you.
It's true, man.
Everybody's acting a role
here and you're right,
the ones that are gonna
win are the same role
that was played out today
is played out tomorrow.
Now you may have a job but is
your head in that same place?
Are you happy that you're
eating shit for 11 hours
at your job and you can't
wait to pick up some fast food
and then go home and then
grind and have nothing
good happen and then start again Tuesday?
I mean it.
Do you love the grind?
Do you love the negativity?
Do you have that patience?
Do you like when you
lose 100 followers a day
instead of gaining a thousand?
Do you like it, I do.
I do, I like it.
I think it's part of the fucking process.
You can't have the
riches without the shit.
So thank you, appreciate you, man.
You got it, man
and I want to say one more thing on that,
the reason I spit real shit
is 'cause I'm selfish.
I know I'm gonna be right
and after you're done fucking with a bunch
of bullshit artists,
you're gonna come back.
Hey guys, just in the interest of time,
let's please keep it at
one question and really
quick please, thank you.
Alright hi, thank you
so much for being here.
So, I come from this world, I
was pretty entrenched in this
about 10 years ago, around
2009 when everything
kind of fell to shit.
I changed my life and
I just moved into another
industry and now I have
a start-up called Superfood
School that is an online
course that helps people
to just get more plants
on their plate, regardless of their diet.
My big question is,
I come from this world,
was pretty entrenched,
arts and entertainment,
this whole business thing
is a big thing for me,
so my question is just
someone moving from creative
to really moving into business,
like I just learned the words scalability
like two years ago,
listening to Frank Kern,
Eben Pagan, all of those
guys, you and just,
not wanting to go back to business school
but really trying to
just get on this wave,
plant based and the online
courses are just like,
it's the wave, so just, yeah.
Here's the problem,
those other guys you just
mentioned, I know them
both, I got love for them
but they're trying to make
you monetize short-term.
They're taking to you
about short-term funnels,
landing page optimization,
trying to get that money
and what happens is,
Frank Kern gets you to ask
your audience for money
too quick when you don't
have an audience yet.
Do you understand?
Yes.
And you know what else?
You know I'm right.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
You can taste it,
so cool, they're not wrong, in my opinion,
other than they want you
to monetize too quick.
Everything's about create the persona,
drive the fucking traffic,
optimize, get emails, free e-book,
but then you sell them the thing,
JV, this guy's got a list,
all this fucking bullshit,
do you understand?
Yes, I do.
And I know you know it is.
What you like about what they're saying is
it's gonna happen fast
and you're gonna make
a buck thirty a year quick
on fucking $12,000 a
month recurring revenue.
30K on a launch, like one launch, yeah.
Fuck that bull fucking
shit, do you understand?
So, instead, there's
tried and true methods,
which is, run the fucking marathon,
keep it humble, put out good content,
it's super okay to ask to sell something
but you gotta believe
in it and if you don't
believe in your $439 e-book because it's a
compilation of shit that they can find,
then you don't do it, but
maybe it's a buck ten,
maybe it's 47, maybe it's something else
but just don't waver for the short term.
- [Audience Member] Okay.
That's all this is.
- [Audience Member]
Okay, got it, thank you.
You're welcome.
(audience applauds)
How you doing, Gary?
- [Gary] Good, brother.
Name is James Eucala,
handle's a bolakills,
I was doing my thing.
- [Gary] Respect.
So two years, I just want to get this
out of the way, it's kind
of surreal just speaking
to you in person 'cause
I've been seeing you
for such a long time but,
two years, I hit kind of
rock bottom and I found
you on a Facebook on
that five minute rant,
randomly and it was
just like, what the fuck
and it just completely changed my mind.
Makes me happy.
Fucking one hour drives everyday,
I changed my health as well.
I took your advice, I lost 30 pounds,
everything very well for me.
(audience applauds)
You look fucking great.
Thank you.
So I took your advice
and I've been doing it
but now, my question is,
I'm at that point now where it's,
I hit my limit, I had
done everything I can but
now I need people to help me out.
Why?
Like you said, I had tripled
down on all of my strength
but I don't want to--
- [Gary] I got it, so
let's go to the next part.
So my next part is,
I'm trying to find people to help me out
and there's a lot of people
that don't wanna help
me out but I have this
weird issue in my head
where it's like, I feel
like I need to repay them.
That's good.
A lot of people are always like,
don't worry, they just
want to help you out
but, I don't know, at the end of the day.
No, I think that's good.
I have the same thing.
When people come through on my team,
work for free, work for cheap, I'm like,
I fucking owe them for life.
There's nothing wrong with that.
Take the chance, have people come on,
they might bring you value,
then it's easy to do right by them,
the other ones, even more interesting,
you bring somebody on,
sorry to point at you,
you bring somebody on
and they suck, right,
and you still do good by them because
that's your operating system,
there's nothing wrong with that.
But how do you?
Pick people?
Not pick people because
there's people that are
on my team that want to help me out and
want me to succeed but
I know a lot of people in my team are
financially unstable and things like that
and then, I know you say, do internships,
do blah, blah, blah, just kind
of give them value for it,
but they don't want that stuff.
So find somebody who does.
And for those people
I try to bring them on
and kind of give them an
opportunity and they're grateful
but as a HR point-of-view,
what do you do to kind of
repay them?
So I do, I'm thinking of--
Let me, real quick, 'cause I see he wants
to take you off, we got
other people, I got this,
real quick.
- [Audience Member] I'm so sorry.
It's super simple, it's
super simple, hear me out.
You're overthinking too much shit.
Here's what you do.
You bring people on
and you take the risk that
you won't get enough value
back in return but then
you do right by them.
You ask them what the fuck
they give a fuck about,
there's 8,000 in my
inbox that literally say
they will work for me
for free for two years
because they know the
Baben and D-Rock and Andy
and Tyler story, because
I'm good enough to pay back
everybody if they do right by me.
Take the risk with a
couple people that doesn't
cost you anything so you can afford it
and just play it out, instead
of overthinking it in theory,
just do it a couple times,
you're gonna learn from the doing.
It's simple as that.
Just give more than you got.
- [Audience Member] Thank you, Gary.
You're welcome.
(audience applauds)
Hi, Gary.
- [Gary] How are you?
I'm good.
My name is Mai and
I came to America in 1975 as
a boat person from Vietnam.
- [Gary] Amazing.
Thank you.
I dealt with racism, bullying,
poverty, the whole bit,
so I decided to write a book.
What, in your opinion,
would be the best way
to market this book because
I'm an unknown writer.
No one knows who I am.
So I would go to
Instagram and I would type
in #bully, #Vietnam,
#everything in your life
and I would look at
the most popular people
on that hashtag, every hour, everyday,
and then you would look at them and
somebody put #Vietnam because that's
where their family's from and they have
7,000 followers and you
DM them and you tell
them you want to send them the book and it
would mean the world to you
if they would shout it out.
You do that 100 times a day,
you'll probably get one in
every thousand to say yes,
once you wrap your head around that,
you just keep doing it over and over.
I'm okay with rejection.
Of course you are, you
were bullied and you faced
racism, you're fucking
set, you've won already.
I'm being, guys, I'm being serious.
If I could ever convince all
of you that your shortcomings
and your detriments are your
strengths, you would win.
If I was six foot four
and ran like a gazelle,
I'd play for the Jets
instead of owning them.
I really need everybody
to have that one sink in
'cause it's the most
important one, so that's it,
do that.
- [Mai] Okay, thank you.
(audience applauds)
Hey, Gary, so I'm a little nervous,
I'm sorry if I'm a little
close to the microphone
or whatever.
- [Gary] You're great.
So, I own a media company, I just founded
about three months ago,
I'm very passionate
about what I do, I feel like
I have a very good drive
and a good product.
So my question is, how can
I get more of that product
in front of the right people,
how can I get the right collaborations,
I mean, obviously
- [Gary] Ask.
Ask?
Yeah, but I mean, for example--
You go to Instagram, you
DM a hundred people a day.
(audience laughs)
You ask, one in every
500 is gonna say yes.
Actually, I guess, let me
ask a different question.
So yeah, sorry, sorry, sorry.
Go ahead.
It's cool, it's cool, go fast.
If were in my shoes--
- [Gary] I'd ask.
Starting a media company--
I'd ask.
My man, my man, that's what I did.
Everybody thinks I was put on,
I built my dad's liquor business for him.
I was 30 fucking two years old,
34 years old when I started VaynerMedia
and I had no equity in my
library, I had nothing.
I built my dad's liquor store for him.
I had zero.
I was 34 years old
and I'd never made more
than $150,000 a year,
even though I built a 60
million dollar business
for my dad.
I had no money.
AJ was graduating from school.
I had no savings 'cause
I bought an apartment
from everything I saved
and, as some of you know,
I finally invested in
Facebook and Twitter,
that launched me but I finally did that.
I had no money.
Do you know how VaynorMedia started?
I asked a bunch of people
that were buying wine from me
if they wanted the way
they saw wine library grow
for their own business
and some dude gave us
an $80 thousand dollar thing,
four of AJ's friends worked for free.
Mike Boyd, Boyd, you here?
- [Mike] Over here.
Hey Boyd, tell these
fuckers how we did it,
Mike, tell them where
you slept some nights.
On the floor, multiple nights.
- [Gary] Say it again.
I slept on the floor of
the office multiple nights,
on purpose, 'cause I wanted to.
People didn't get paid.
(audience applauds)
It's so fun to have Boyd
and have Dustin here,
'cause they know the truth.
They know me before this.
You think I'm joking,
you think my daddy gave me a liquor store,
you're fucking confused.
Do you understand?
You know what I did, bro?
I fucking asked, you know why?
I don't give a shit when people say no.
You know what that means?
Somebody finally says yes
and you fucking start.
You want collabs, ask them.
You want to do something with A Boogie,
you wanna do something with Champion,
you wanna do something Cristall,
fucking ask them.
- [Audience Member] Yes, sir.
That's it.
- [Audience Member] So
let me ask you this.
Can I collab with you?
Let's go.
(audience laughs)
You should have started with the ask.
Hi, I'm Lila Hart, stand-up comedian
living in Los Angeles,
originally from Seattle.
My question for you is
how do you remain so fearless
in your entrepreneurial
endeavors and why does
kindness matter so much to you?
Kindness matters 'cause
my legacy matters to me
way more than anything else and that's how
I live my life and the
way I stay fearless is
there's no alternative.
I'm not scared of losing
because I don't allow
any of you to judge me.
Guys, you're only scared
to lose 'cause you're
worried about what other
people are gonna say.
My losses are my losses,
get the fuck out of my system.
They're my losses.
You think I give a fuck what you think?
You think if I lost everything
your comment of I fucking knew it,
he was snake oil salesman,
he never had anything,
you think that would bother me?
That shit would fucking motivate me 'cause
when I rise again like a phoenix,
I'll stick it in your fucking mouth.
I'm fearless because, listen,
I know your story, we've
interacted a little bit
at that Vid Summit, now here,
you've dealt with way fucking worse
than fucking somebody firing
you or your business failing,
so you're fucking good too.
Thank you.
(audience applauds)
ComplexCon, makes some noise!
GaryVee's in the house, baby, sorry.
- [Gary] He's feeling it, he's feeling it.
Come on, come on.
- [Gary] Respect, respect.
So real quick.
- [Gary] They keep it tight around here.
So just to give people some context,
I met Gary for the first time downstairs,
definitely became the
biggest fanboy of all time.
D-Rock definitely captured it.
I was just like, yo Gary,
I love this shit, man,
you hook me up but,
14 months ago, launched a podcast
called Purpose in the Youth,
it's about unfolding the
stories of passionate people
after graduating college, you
need to find that passion.
You've given me so much value,
D-Rock, shout out to Baben,
he's been on the podcast,
thank you, bro,
shout out to your entire team.
- [Gary] Thank you.
You've given me so much
value and I know for a fact
that one day we will be in
some type of partnership
for this podcast.
In the meantime,
what value can I bring to
you through my podcast?
Just keep doing your thing.
I need nothing, man.
You fucking winning is fucking all I want.
I'm gonna get mine by
myself, you go do you.
(audience applauds)
Nothing, not even like
a Gary shout out in it?
I was yelling at fucking Schmidt 'cause
the sneaker release on the
14th I thought was gonna
be like me being there and
doing what I did downstairs,
instead he's like, yo,
we're doing this party
and we're gonna invite 150
VIPs and I'm like fuck,
that sucks.
I don't like stuff.
I don't want you to do anything for me.
You fucking executing on the thesis,
the shit that I'm trying
to penetrate people's
skulls and hearts in here with,
you doing that fucking
pays me back 10x, do it.
- [Audience Member] All day.
(audience applauds)
Yo, how you doing, I'm Marcus Terell,
I have eight million followers
on all social media platforms,
hello to everybody.
- [Gary] I'm aware.
So, basically in 2016, you emailed me,
you said come see me, it never happened.
Alright, so we gonna get to that, alright,
but my question is,
since you're an investor and you invested
in so many companies
like Twitter and Snapchat
and Facebook, are you invested into
Blockchain and Bitcoin?
So I bought Bitcoin in 2014,
I just need all of you
to eat that for a minute.
I love showing my Coinbase to people,
they're like, fuck.
I put in 25K, it's worth like a million,
so, Marcus, listen,
I think Blockchain's way
bigger than people realize,
like people are fucking with
it like on a Bitcoin level
then people a little smarter
are on the Ethereum level,
but when you understand
what the Blockchain is,
my big thing with the Blockchain is
it can literally overthrow
America and China and Russia.
It's that powerful.
It's a platform of trust and
we can do shit with each other
and everybody else is out.
It's so heady, man,
I understand it theoretically,
I haven't spent a lot
of time in it, right,
but I've been spending more lately.
There's a lot of bullshit
ICOs, get rich quick bullshit
that's starting to happen.
I need all the dust, thank you,
I need all the dust to
settle a little bit.
I'm watching.
My favorite time is
when I'm like the cobra
in the grass, I loved social media like
2006, '07,'08, 'cause I
was just like creeping,
I was like in there, I was watching it,
that's how I am with Blockchain right now,
that's how I am with AR,
with Voice I'm a little
louder 'cause I was in
the grass two years ago
with Voice and Alexa,
Scales and podcast but now I'm out.
I think it's super fascinating.
I think there's a lot of
people that know a lot more
than me, which is why I
don't spit on it a whole lot
but it's big big, like
building on top of it,
building on top of Ethereum
and taking advantage of it,
there's real things.
The same way you hacked,
I watch how you hacked
your social, you did
it a little different,
we can talk about it any way you want but,
I think if you would deploy
some of that hacker culture
into Blockchain, you might
find some real fruitful shit.
Alright, thank you.
(audience applauds)
Yes, hello, my name's Luke Penco,
I met you downstairs.
- [Gary] I remember.
Quick question about audio.
I teach English to Italians, right?
- [Gary] I'm aware.
About starting a podcast and for them,
obviously more advance
I'd give them transcripts
and stuff like that but
what's the best way to deploy,
I know you're talking about
not monetizing too early,
doing the whole Frank Kerns stuff, right
but obviously you gotta make
some money at the same time, right?
Well, you do
but real quick before you go anywhere.
How much?
To me, I'm doing this more for everybody,
I'll get back to you.
Of course you have to make money,
my question is, how much?
Like if you want it real, real
bad and you can't breathe,
why can't you at 28
live with four roommates
in a bullshit place?
I thought you told me
you wanted it so bad?
There's a great Russian saying,
it doesn't translate into English,
I've never heard it as
an English expression
but it basically translates into
you can't put your ass on two toilets
and that's what everybody's
trying to do here.
Everybody wants it and want
to build a big business
but they also want the
money in the short term
to live that lifestyle.
So, we've talked four times already here,
my big thing, I mean it and I'm excited,
we've talked, my big
thing with you that I'm
trying to figure out is at 27, 28, right,
I need you to really realize
that you should just,
I feel like you could win based
on our four interactions here.
No listen, I'm being serious with you,
I don't think it's a negative.
I'm trying to make everybody understand
that I've been paying attention
for the last 12 hours.
I just think you're impatient.
I guess I'm trying to balance,
I don't need this crazy.
You need almost nothing,
you know that, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You could legitimately go
on a social media campaign
and sleep in people's houses
and have no rent, right,
you know that, right?
You guys know that, right?
You just don't need
that much money to live.
But you gotta make some, right?
- [Gary] Why?
Just give all free shit?
The longer you give free
shit and you're good,
the more you'll get back at the end.
The person that can hold
the breath the longest wins.
Well, then you gotta have like a side job
or something.
Yeah.
- [Luke] For like ever?
For 10 years anyway.
Yeah, that's exactly what you should do.
I brought the 27th team flip challenge
to all the creators
because if you're going
to the Goodwill and garage
sales and shit like that
and making $400 a week that way,
well then you don't have to sell bullshit
fucking courses on your podcast,
which makes everybody
unsubscribe to your bullshit.
Will you be on my podcast?
- [Gary] What's that?
Will you be in my podcast?
You do 40 episodes and
I'll be on your podcast.
Alright.
Can I shake your hand?
No, okay.
(audience applauds)
- [Bobby] Hello.
Hello.
I'm not comfortable on mic,
so I'll just start off
by saying that hello,
nice to meet you, Gary.
- [Gary] Good to meet you.
Huge inspiration, my name's Bobby Torrez,
I'm from Orlando, Florida.
- [Gary] What up, Bobby?
Quick question, I work in the tech sector
so I'm asking you as an investor,
what's your thoughts on augmented reality
and virtual reality and the
opportunity in this industry
and for our generation?
I think AR is huge and it's here and
you should look at it
and with the new update
in the iPhone and the kit,
everybody here should
understand augmented reality.
You're living it, that's why all that shit
that Snapchat's doing,
little butterfly pops up
or you throw up fucking
rainbows, it's here.
It's here, I like it.
Consumer VR I hate.
I think it's 10 years away,
nobody here has spent
three hours in a VR world
in the last month,
that shit's super far away
but when it gets here,
that shit is gonna be big
and I think when everybody realizes,
it's fun to talk to a young crowd,
the fact that all of you are
gonna wear contact lenses
in your life and your
brain is gonna switch from
real life to augmented reality,
like Santa Claus is
sitting here and having
this keynote with me, to virtual reality
where you switch into a world,
this mixed reality world that
you're all gonna live in,
you think all this
technology's crazy and fly now,
you think the iPhone X is
rad, facial recognition,
this is fucking garbage.
This shit's garbage to where
we're going in 10 years
and so, there's some kid
in here who's gonna make
10 million dollars a year selling virtual
fucking sneakers, but
it's gonna take 15 years.
Fair enough, fair enough.
I'm working in that space right now,
so it's yeah.
If you're doing it for b to b,
there's a lot but if you think consumers
are gonna fuck with VR,
it's gonna take a much
longer time than you think.
We started in the consumer
space and then pivoted.
No shit.
Cool.
Thank you very much.
You're welcome.
(audience applauds)
She gets the mic.
Hi, I'm Bianca Richelle,
I'm from California,
well, not California, San Francisco.
(Gary laughs)
- [Gary] How old are you?
I'm nine.
It's so nice to meet you.
Nice to meet you too.
I'm a rapper and a business owner.
I come to events like ComplexCon,
I come to network because I push myself
and create partnerships with the brands.
Do you think I'm going
at it the wrong way?
You are definitely not going
about it the wrong way.
(audience laughs)
(audience applauds)
Little one, you might be going about it
the best fucking way here.
(audience laughs)
Are you enjoying it?
Yeah.
You love it?
What are you gonna do when you grow up?
Well, I'm a rapper, so I really,
I dream about going on tours,
everybody here, they're coming to see you,
I want them to be like that to me.
I love that.
Listen to me,
can I give you a real, real,
real good piece of advice
that's gonna be really
hard for you to take
but please remember it
and hopefully when we
chop up this video, we'll send it to you?
- [Bianca] Uh-huh.
The number one thing you have is time.
You have something in
here that all of us envy,
which is an extra 30
years, an extra 20 years,
an extra 15 years, do you understand?
- [Bianca] Yeah.
You can't get caught up
in the game that most
nine to 11 year old
entrepreneurs are getting
caught up in that I talk to.
(audience laughs)
Oh what, you don't see
what I'm doing on music.ly?
Listen to me,
that was funny, right?
My life's funny.
Listen, listen to me,
the thing that a lot of
single digit entrepreneurs
are getting caught up
with is you care too much
about how many subscribers
and followers you got.
If you promise me this,
it will help you so much.
If you just make the songs
that are in your heart.
If you just make the content you want.
If I could get you to
just never look at how
many followers you have
for the next 10 years,
you will win, it's gonna be hard,
all your friends are gonna ask how many,
everybody here cares how
many and they're grown
but if you can get to that
place where you don't care
about that one thing,
it will help you so much
you could never imagine.
Can I tell you something else?
- [Bianca] Yeah.
If you talk about your real life,
which is obviously very
different than our real life,
based on how you see things in the world,
it will be really interesting shit.
Yeah, that's how my songs are.
I don't tell fake stuff,
I don't wanna tell fake stuff,
I wanna tell my life
story and how I got here.
I love it.
Keep getting your thing, girl.
I love you.
(audience applauds)
Can you come up here.
I want to take a picture with you.
- [Crew Member] That's it guys,
thank you so much for coming out.
All of Gary's team, please
just meet right here
and we're gonna have you guys
standing by to go backstage.
All of Gary's team, just right here.
All the rest of audience,
go home (laughs).
Thank you guys, have a good night.
Yeah, yeah, hold on, hold on,
you know what,
yeah, yeah, let's do this real quick,
this would really matter a lot to me.
This is when we can give some real love.
It's real fun.
Do you have an Instagram yet?
Yeah.
What is it?
It's Bianca Rochelle,
B-I-A-N-C-A underscore,
R-I-C-H-E-L.
Hold on, hold on.
We're fucking old.
Bianca underscore, there you go, hold on,
you know what I'll do, this
is an even better move.
I'm gonna follow you right now
and then everybody will go to my account
and look at the last
person I followed, B-I-A?
B-I-A-N-C-A.
Underscore?
R-I-C-H-E-L-L-E.
Okay, that's you, right?
Yeah.
Yo, she's got 28 five.
(audience applauds)
Let's get her to 50K, uh.
Okay.
Thank you guys so much,
I have nothing but love for you.
(audience applauds)
That's real cute.
I wish you well.
(relaxed hip hop music)
Hope you enjoyed,
what was your biggest takeaway other than
I have a shit load of Jet's jerseys?